all right so we've talked about a lot of
stuff that we sort of agree on I haven't
agreed with everything but I'm letting
you talk people always yell at me they
say you don't you don't yell back at
your other stuff so the gay-marriage
them hmm
let's talk gay marriage sure you're not
big on gay marriage no I'm not Edie not
on a social level I think the government
ought to be completely out of the
business of marriage I think the
government sucks at everything is my is
my short message for today the
government is terrible at everything if
the government's goal is to forward
traditional marriage uh turley failed
obviously as you don't mind it being out
of the business of traditional marriage
at all no I think that I think the
government should be out of all marriage
I think the government stinks at this
you know that now I will say that do I
think that the I think the idea of the
government subsidizing gay marriage is
silly because I don't think that there's
societal benefit to gay marriage if
you're going to make the argument that
government should be involved in
marriage at all there's not even an
argument with which I agree at this
point the way it is right now right
let's just go from that okay so that be
so before I get there yeah one quick
point the reason I want the government
out of the business of marriage is
because now that the government has
enshrined gay marriage the next step is
going to be going to religious people
and telling them they have to engage
with same-sex weddings so as a religious
person this is problematic to me I want
a society in which I can do it I want
and I don't have to care what you think
and you can do what you want and you
don't have to care what I think right
doesn't mean you get to come into my
synagogue and get married it also
doesn't mean that I have to go to your
gay wedding right see that's an
interesting place to have the discussion
because I would argue for gay marriage
for the exact reasons I don't want the
government involved in all of these
things right and that's exactly why gay
marriage should exist and I think if
Rand Paul had hit that point harder it
would have made a sensible libertarian
argument unlimited government and you
know what you want to marry a dude go
ahead and you want to smoke weed oh you
you're right well I tend to agree both
of those things I agree with and by the
way I find people who smoke weed
unbelievably irritating but that's not
my business
I mean this is the beauty of America is
you don't have to give a crap what I
think we said this is the end the show
by taking the bong hit oh yeah well but
the the the as far as the the secondary
argument about let's let's take the
predicate that government is now
involved in marriage yeah should
government subsidize gay marriage and
straight marriage the same way my answer
is no because the only purpose for the
government getting involved in marriage
is the procreation of the next
generation and the raising of that
generation
and it's my belief that a man and a
woman do a better job of raising a child
and producing children obviously
biologically than two men or two women
but isn't isn't the child part of it
sort of secondary I mean there are
plenty of people that may get married
gay couples and straight couples that
don't have kids this is i retaining of
itself isn't just about but at a
governmental level i don't care about
those people or meaning like i care that
i'm happy that they're happy but i don't
i don't really care what they do like it
didn't it doesn't the the government
theoretically has an interest in the
production of the next generation right
right that's the only interest in
marriage so in fact you could even make
a case that the government ought to be
giving you know basically tax benefits
for for having kids and no benefit for
marriage right but the truth is the
reason that this was created in the
first place obviously is because before
the advent I mean long before the advent
of modern birth control the the fair
assumption was that if you were having
sex then you were going to get pregnant
right at least if you were having
straight sex you were going to have
pregnant you were going to get pregnant
and thus we wanted to incentivize people
to stick around for that because single
motherhood is bad for the community and
so we're going to subsidize that with
tax benefits by the way there is no
there is no marriage benefit there's a
marriage penalty my wife and I pay a
significantly higher tax rate because we
have a combined income right so you're
not against so despite coming from some
sort of it's not a religious area so
that's right so that'll make a religious
so that's what I want to distinguish
because of court because we should be
for separation of church and state and I
think you are for separation of church
so the separation of church and state
means I just want to make a quick
distinction separation of church and
state doesn't mean that I can't bring my
religious values to bear in how I vote
it just means that I can't leverage a
Jewish ritual on you there's no
establishment of Jewish religion or a
Christian religion but I should be able
to make a secular argument for why what
I'm saying is right is my general rule
because otherwise we're operating in
different spheres I cite the Bible it
makes no difference to you you don't
care about the Bible right so right so
I'm I'm a secular I would consider I
mean I'm an atheist so it doesn't ISM is
is that Nick and irrelevant in every
other respect
I like curb you like herb who could be
in that cultural Judaism like bagels and
matzo balls I don't care you know pretty
good okay so that's not gonna help with
that but so you're making the the
distinction between this isn't coming
from a religious place now I think part
of the problem when it comes to gay
marriage is that a huge portion of the
Christian Right is trying to impose
their religious values on this self
isn't religious but now for the policy
can this is where I'm making a
distinction yeah the rationale for
people voting can still be religious but
if the policy is not religious if
there's a secular ration now this is
what Scalia said about it actually if
there's a secular rationale to it then
the motivations of the voters don't
matter like I don't care what the
motivation of the voter is in virtually
any circumstance I matter what the vote
is and if somebody wants to vote for
lower taxes I don't care whether they're
doing it because they're on principle
for lower taxes or whether they
personally want lower taxes on their
income I just care about the outcome of
the vote the outcome okay so basically
you don't care about gay marry as this
country stands right now you simply
don't care your one concern though is
that ultimately this will lead to the
government forcing gay marriage on
synagogues that don't want to have it or
mosques that don't want to not
ultimately like now in California there
they've already passed laws that you
have to teach them sex marriage in
public schools for example like it
changes the nature of the teaching my
view on that is I don't know why that I
went to public school for elementary and
part of junior high I don't understand
why the government is teaching me
anything about this stuff this is for my
parents to teach me like this is a
values thing right so I guess that's
sort of where it's just values just get
conflated with what we're taught like
well I've sort of said no I mean they're
not values to math right there no back
the break but they're no values to
biology they're no they're their values
to history which is why it's dicey and
it's and it's disingenuous what the left
is done with the education system there
are multiple perspectives on history and
the monopolistic takeover of the liberal
arts is a real problem yeah and you can
have multiple perspectives on that but
we're not teaching marriage in the
context of history or English we're
teaching in the context of science which
has nothing to do with anything
so when again you APC comes in I mean
when I was when when they're doing sex
ed when I was in junior high they're
making a big deal out of the idea that
everybody you know everybody is equally
likely do to get aids for example not
true I mean it's just not true but it's
a behaviorally driven disease or if you
know I will never get AIDS right barring
a barring a blood transfusion oh that
has AIDS I don't I don't do intravenous
drugs and I don't have promiscuous acts
and I was a virgin when I married my
wife and she was a virgin when she
married me so where
safe yeah right we're good we're about
as safe as you can get on this and so I
don't like the again the facts being
trumped by what we wish the facts were
so that we could push certain political
agendas right so how do you then taking
this argument from a secular place how
do you then feel being in the same party
that of so many people that are taking
it from right-wing Christian place
because there is an agreement there just
seemingly odd alliance there that I
think is really I agree with them on the
end point I even agree with them
religiously I just don't think they're
good spokespeople for their cause I mean
I think that if you if you are if you're
chief citation to your opposition to gay
marriage is Leviticus 18:22 I don't
think that that's a solid argument
that's going to convince a lot of people
right I think that you know there are
better arguments against gay marriage
than that room and so you know this is
something I talk about at religious
schools and I've been asked by you know
pastors and rabbis and priests to talk
to students about okay you have these
religious principles is there any
justification outside of the Bible says
so for why this is correct and as a
religious person who's actually thought
through his positions I tend to believe
there is like I seen as a religious
person I believe that God didn't create
stupid rules so if you believed that God
didn't creates stupid rules then you
have to come up with some sort of
justification for the rules that are
being expressed like there's something
you can't understand this just an
article of faith but but the big ones
about human behavior
there should be a decent rationale you
can explain to people who don't buy into
Revelation sure so there I would just
say well you're basing your belief in
God it's just a belief not anything that
could be proven so anyone that's basing
anything on religion is just basement
that's true on some unproven thing that
is right okay I want that nothing to do
with my life that which is which is fine
and that's why we live in America good
yeah but but but I will say this every
belief system is based on something
unproven all of them human rights means
nothing where do you get them your basis
of human right from a feeling how about
that mom exactly objective well right
but that's a that's a blend so you're
saying basically we're the Liberals
would say I'm for this because I'm for
gay people I want gay people to be able
to do what they want to do and right you
know pursue happiness like anyone else
you would say well just this
new government and whatever so I can't
there's not a lot of no there's not a
lot of conflict here yeah my
governmental policy because I'm
basically a libertarian is I don't care
about that yeah I mean I again they come
to strengthen that group of people so
clearly we don't agree it's getting
don't agree on this thing but I
understand your rationale and you're not
trying to stop gay people from getting
married I think right now I think right
now the next conflict is not going to
come from the right it's gonna come from
the left pushing the ball meaning that
it's gonna come from the case in Oregon
with this Baker who you know doesn't
want to service the same-sex wedding
doesn't want to actually have to cater
it yeah right as a you know I think that
good-hearted people should say fine you
do what you want go across the street to
the bakery like who care that's what I
would say and this is the difference you
know liberal and a leftist yeah in a
nutshell this is the difference between
a liberal and a leftist the liberal says
your business I don't care a leftist
says no no I think it's imperative that
you will be made to care right and Erik
Erikson's phrase he'll be made to care
somebody's gonna a man will come to your
house with a gun and he will tell you
that if you do not cater this wedding
this is what they they were forced to a
$175,000 fine for not catering a lesbian
wedding there's bakery across the street
you know the this is this is is really
nefarious stuff so this is where you
asked where the momentum comes from yeah
this is where the momentum comes from so
when I make an argument to conservatives
and religious people that the government
ought to get out of the business of
marriage I'm not saying that because I'm
Pro gay marriage I'm very much anti gay
marriage in the social sense I don't
think that that you know homosexual as a
religious person I think homosexuality
is a sin I think lots of things are sins
that people engage in I think they
should be free to engage in them but as
a religious person that's not that's not
my thing I don't think that gay marriage
is is a great massively good thing for
society on a social level but on a
governmental level if you guys don't
just get out of this business entirely
the left has no end point
their only endpoint is using the
government as a club against use and now
that they've got gay marriage it will go
- it will go - we're going to stop
accrediting schools that don't teach gay
marriage or hire homosexual employees
right and you've got Catholic churches
they don't want to pay the health
benefits of somebody's gay partner
that's a Catholic Church why should it
have to right but the left would say no
they have to right you will be made to
care this is you're a bad person if you
don't do this and so if so what are my
arguments the right is where I'm a
sensible liberal right
this is yeah but but this way you'd
actually get heavy argument from the not
so sensible liberals probably including
all the Democratic nominees the the the
fact is that what I'm saying is the best
argument for the libertarian position on
the right here is gonna be a rearguard
action it's not gonna be it's better for
straight people be and it's bad for gay
marriage to get it out of that realm
it's I think that if you want to fight
against gay marriage do it on the social
level with your church teach your kids
what you want to teach them but when it
comes to when it comes to making this
argument to conservatives the real
argument is if you don't take power out
of the hands of government if you don't
take that ring away from gollum and
throw it into Mount Doom then it will be
used against you there will the the
government is just government is the
ring so does this I my direct message at
the top of the show I was talk about
just how stupid our election system is
and how everything's down to sound bites
and everything you know our debate is so
nonsensical and all that so everything
you just laid out there is a much more
clean and clear explanation and where
you actually are separating church and
state and doing the intellectual rigor
to make a sensible argument where if
they talk for a little bit that they've
talked about gay marriage which I'm glad
because I don't think it should be
talked about that much it let it be and
that that would be fine in my opinion
but nobody you know Marco Rubio will
talk about the family but he's purely
doing it from a religious perspective
there's an identity politics that's been
created on the right in response to the
identity politics to the left so if
we're gonna be attacked as religious
people we have to talk as religious
people right so have to go preach from a
pulpit and if I don't cite you know if I
don't say Genesis to talk about a man
shall leave his man shall leave his
parents and cling to his wife if I don't
if I don't cite that then I haven't
spoken the in code that shows that I
care about the values of people like you
and this is the way the political game
is played so again I sort of wish that
Americans would see through the
political game on all sides meaning I
wish religious people would just say I
agree I understand you're anti gay
marriage and I also understand what
you're doing here to protect religious
people and you don't have to cite Bible
verses at me to prove it and in you end
up with IDIA sees like Donald Trump on
stage waving around a Bible pretending
he gives a damn what's in it
right after two marriages and several
adulterous affairs and all that and
bragging about having his experiences
with married women standing up there
with a Bible and going this is an even
better book than the odd of the deals
like that if this is this is how you
vote if you're able to be pandered to
that way that's a sad
Terry on American politics and in its
way it's really no different from
Hillary Clinton going to the black
community and saying you're the victims
you're the victims and now I'm gonna
speak the language you understand here's
here's how you know that I care about
you yeah I'm not big into caring you
know I think that people who personally
care about you are generally people who
want the power to control your life the
only people that that I want power in
their lives and they want power in my
life or my immediate family that's it
you know my parents my sister's my wife
my children and they're independent
human beings too right so caring caring
is the is the way that caring is the way
that the left controls like they never
they don't come with the jackboots first
they first come and they say we care so
much about you we have to do these
things for you and by the way we brought
some guns to help out right so it shows
sort of the the beauty or the scariness
of identity politics because it sounds
really good I guess what that's why they
always say socialism oh come with this
big smile right yeah exactly this is
john glover explaining liberal fascism
yeah yeah all right so we only have a
couple minutes left but let's just knock
out a couple other things so I saw when
you were on Piers Morgan with that whole
gun thing we went and I watched it again
in preparation for this and I never
liked Piers Morgan I thought he was
doing a talk show the wrong way I hope
people don't view me in that way but
what you did with him in the argument
was really kind of brilliant and it goes
it goes to some of the eleven I like
land and before but before I even ladies
anything I I don't really agree with
your with your stance on guns
so can you sort of recap what happened
well sure well first of all like Trump
now that you've complimented me like
what happened in that debate is that
Piers Morgan had basically been doing a
lot of the things we're talking about
from weeks he'd been saying after Sandy
Hook that anybody who disagreed with him
on gun control the only possible reason
to disagree with him is because you
don't care about what happened on gun
control and you stopped Barack Obama do
this you know after the after the last
mass shooting right after I'm quote
community college and and he got up
there and he did the teary-eyed routine
and I don't like tears stop like just
just give me your policy so what so what
I said he can fake the tears we're
saying this I in a weird way I don't
need his peering out over here I think
Obama and I think Obama is in unusually
skilled politician and I think
himself up to tears I think that I think
that good actors can I think that you
know the idea that the emotion is fake
is I don't think the emotions fake but
the emotion of actors isn't fake either
if you talk to actors who work
themselves up to tears they actually
feel sad when they are crying that's how
you get yourself to cry right right I
think Obama worked himself up there
otherwise otherwise you'd be crying
every other press conference I mean he's
talking about all sorts of crap that
goes on in the country that's terrible
like how many every time he gets out
there and he talks about the economy be
crying I mean you'd be completely
emotionally unstable it's one of the two
so it's so so what I said to Piers
Morgan as I said you're a bully and the
way that you bully people is you stand
on the graves of the children of Sandy
Hook to push your political agenda and
he didn't know how to come back from
that because that was his entire
strategy and now it had been unmasked
and actually during the break he had
planned to bring in a kid who'd been
shot and was in a wheelchair and say
well you've said it to me now say it's
this small pool child and he couldn't do
it because if you'd done that I
immediately would have said first you
stood on the graves of the kids and now
you're standing on this poor guys
wheelchair it's terrible yeah but it's
so so that was sort of the content of
the argument he tried to he tried to
throw the the Ronald Reagan was in favor
of banning assault weapons at me I don't
care as I've said what Ronald Reagan had
to say he was a guy sometimes he's right
sometimes he's wrong yeah so he wasn't a
god is that yes affirming that as a
religious person I only have one and you
got him yeah okay so that's not the one
we knew that was right it's just not
Reagan this is not Reagan okay got it
and I know because he's not back right
he could be weird so it's so my feelings
on the gun thing is that basically I
because I believe in the Second
Amendment people should have access to
guns I as you clear it's clear after an
hour together I'm not a huge fan of the
government so I do believe people should
be able to protect themselves and all of
those things what I think is that we're
we should be able to control it a little
bit more than we are I think that the
NRA does wield too much power and then I
would say at the same time as I was like
to say two things could be true at the
same time we have a massive mental
health problem in this country so and
that's the part that we're not talking
about because every commercial for every
cable news channel is for some other
drug that it turns out that some crazy
percentage of these shooters are hot
right so when it comes to gun violence
there's two problems there's inner-city
violence which really is a matter of
gang violence and people shooting each
other unfortunately
because they're because they're involved
in gangs and this is what's happening
every day in Chicago but we but never a
man Los Angeles and Washington DC and
all the major cities I mean this is all
the heavily gun controlled areas
Democratic areas these are the places
where people are getting killed on mass
and then you have the mass shooting
issue and the mass shooting issue is
largely because in the 1960s and 1970s
this is the one area where I think the
government actually should be involved
in the 1960s and 1970s there was a
decision that was made basically all
across the country to empty out all the
mental facilities because there was an
idea that went around the country and
gained a lot of traction that mental
illness was basically One Flew Over the
Cuckoo's Nest nobody was seriously crazy
everybody was just eccentric right and
this is why you have a mass growth in
homeless people in 1960 there how many
people do you think in 1960 were in
mental institutions in the United States
I mean I can't imagine I would guess
half a million half a million people
half a million people right and we had
half the population then right today
there's 25,000 people in mental
facilities so you've got a lot of
violent people on the streets and so you
have a lot of violent people on the
streets you're going to end up with more
mass shootings and that's why every time
there's a mass shooting almost
invariably it's somebody who is crazy
and we've known they're crazy and
involuntary commitment laws are really
really difficult because you have to
show that the person is a threat to
themselves or others as opposed to the
old standard which was they're incapable
of caring for themselves one of the big
problems with paranoid schizophrenia
which is afflicted a lot of these
shooters is that you you have you have a
condition where you literally can't even
recognize that you have the condition so
you won't take your drugs if we let you
out you'll just go off the drugs and
you'll go right back to doing what it
was that you were doing in the first but
even the drugs often is part of it it's
people that are off the drugs and it's
people that are on most of the people
most of the people who are committing
these acts are not on heavy medication
most of the people who are committing
these acts are people who've gone off
their medication and they have
significant mental illness and they need
to be medicated so you know this is an
area where the mental health system is
dramatically underfunded the laws are
complete when it comes to people who
legitimately cannot take care of
themselves I'm talking and I'm speaking
as somebody whose grandfather was was a
schizophrenic who went into a mental
hospital they gave him lithium and then
he spent the rest of his life as a happy
productive human being right these these
are things that might not have been
possible now and and this is you know
this is an area where I actually you
know think that there's there there is a
role for the government in this because
this is John Locke would have thought
the same John Locke said this in in in
his writings he said that you know the
problem of mental illness is one that
sort of falls on society as a whole
because you have a group of people who
can't take care of themselves that's the
real problem with mass shootings you
know taking my guns away from me or
taking another law-abiding persons gun
away from them that's not going to to
stop the mass shooter in fact you know
it's probably going to create more mass
shootings because now I can't defend
myself so would you say the NRA is a
problem at all in within this I think
the NRA is an incredibly valuable
organization because it's pushing
against people on the other side I don't
have to agree with everything the NRA
says to think that they're an incredibly
valuable organization that's channeling
the the legal hopes of a lot of
Americans to protect the Second
Amendment and we're about one vote away
on the Supreme Court from the Second
Amendment disappearing entirely so yeah
let's just do some stuff in that that's
how this so with this whole thing with
Scalia right now and this spot where do
you stand on this it seems to me that
Obama has to nominate someone that's his
job he's the president are you with me
so far
he's the president right now he can't he
doesn't have to of course he right okay
and now that it's a I don't care if he
does that's as you say he has the
capacity to do it it's one of the only
things that he's actually allowed to do
as president that he's doing as opposed
to all the other things he's doing which
he's not allowed to do but we got to
finish up you have to focus on this one
so all right so we're in agreement on
that and then they say it'll be up to
the Senate to either confirm this person
or not they don't have to give them an
up or down vote though right right and
whatever they want so what do you make
of the you know Mitch McConnell and the
rest of these guys that are like you
know he shouldn't even nominate anybody
and all that idiotic line of argument I
mean I think a really dumb line of
argument listen I wrote my I went to
Harvard Law School and I wrote my
third-year paper at Harvard Law School
on the idea that Marbury versus Madison
was wrongly decided I don't think that
the Supreme Court should have the
capacity to decide for everyone like for
conservatives to think that the entire
future of the Constitution rests on
school one guy not dying is really sad
right and and and the reason for that is
because the Supreme Court has now been
seen as this great moral arbiter I don't
think it is I think that the Supreme
Court has been responsible for some of
the worst decisions in in human history
I mean the Supreme Court is responsible
for Roe which is a disaster the Supreme
Court was responsible for Plessy versus
Ferguson everybody always wants to talk
about Brown versus Board if they've
gotten Plessy right in the first place
you know need Brown versus Board and
segregation ends in 1900 so this
so the Supreme Court is a serious
problem there nine unelected people
which I don't even care about the
unelected but there there are nine
people who are given the power to
control everybody's life in the name of
a document that most of them don't even
take seriously so is that the irony with
the Supreme Court that they're supposed
to be above partisan politics and yet
the whole system to get them there is
partisan and they're then their party
themselves I mean Elena Kagan is a
hardcore Democrat Elena Kagan was the
Solicitor General for for Barack Obama
come on I mean I went to she was the
Dean when I was at Harvard Law School
she was a hardcore leftist then you know
the idea that people are free of
politics and what they call legal
realist I believe that that that
virtually everybody is is has their
perspective on life and that comes out
in how they and how they adjudicate and
you have to work very hard to remove
yourself from that I think most judges
don't I think most judges rule based on
what they feel like Anthony Kennedy you
can't tell them regardless what you
think about same-sex marriage you cannot
tell me that the Constitution of the
United States or the Fourteenth
Amendment there to which was ratified in
1868 was demanding that the states not
passed laws in favor of traditional
marriage that's absurd
well sir no but he but equal protection
he was using that on protection area
that we should all be treated equally as
munch of crap because equal protection
does not mean that that that everybody
that a law should have an equal effect
on everyone no law has an equal effect
on everyone the question is whether the
law itself whether the law itself
discriminates against someone on the
basis of an immutable characteristic and
one of the problems with with the whole
gays are blacks is that gays are not
blacks I mean the fact is that a gay
person who never has sex with another
man is not going to manifest their
homosexuality in a way that society
cares about they may be gay they may
have a sex advertisers gonna shoot up a
place well maybe maybe he will maybe he
won't I mean I assume there I assume
that for the last couple of hundred
couple of thousand years when gays were
not treated well in Western society that
not all the the squirrely gay people
were going and killing folks you know
gay people have the same self-control
that straight people do I don't think
they're any better I don't think they're
any worse in terms of their sexual
self-control mmm-hmm I will say that I
think men in general are less good in
terms of sexual assault control than
women so which explains why I agree oh
yeah I mean which is why gay men have
sex with more people than then straight
men because women don't want to have sex
with men as much as men wanna have sex
with men have strong sex drives right
yeah but that's well off topic back to
the Scalia for a second yeah the the
problem here is that the Republican
Party when they say things like it's the
time line it isn't the time line okay if
somebody replaces Justice Scalia who's
over the left and I don't care when this
is if Hillary gets elected if we're if
we're twenty years from now one more
vote on the Supreme Court and the
leftist on the court do not see the
Constitution as a piece of law right to
be interpreted like the Sherman
Antitrust Act or like Obamacare they see
that they see the Constitution is a
piece of poetry to be interpreted as
their feelings dictate and this is the
point that I'm making about sanity
through line through sort of everything
we're talking that's right and this is
the point that I'm making about Kennedy
specifically in the gay marriage
decision there is not one iota of
evidence that the law that when it was
written meant anything to this effect or
that it meant to leave an open space for
the Supreme Court to come in and
leverage down on States same-sex
marriage laws mean what they mean when
they're written they don't mean what
they're what they mean 200 years from
now if somebody picks up this interview
in two hundred years and starts to read
into my perspective that I'm super pro
homosexual behavior I would be a little
bit surprised right but that's
essentially what happened in 1868 he's
taking a clause that was written by a
bunch of people who were very much not
in favor of even for forget homosexual
marriage who criminalized sodomy right
and saying to them okay well those
people really meant what they really
meant here was Pro same-sex marriage if
you want to make same-sex marriage legal
make it legal you know that's that's
what you can do through the ballot box
is the beauty of a republic but you
don't get to have nine on the left two
judges who are these special moral
people who've been dinged by the hand of
God I don't believe I believe all human
beings are capable of good I believe all
human beings are capable of evil I
believe all human beings are selfish and
all they are capable of altruism
I don't believe that there are nine
perfect human beings who sit on the
Supreme Court and rule us is a magical
angelic Oleg Archy I think that's a
pretty solid ending to this what do you
think sounds good to me yeah I mean well
I think what we did here was exactly
what I want this to be that we don't
have to agree on everything but I do
sense a sort of new center coming
together with people that are on the
right that was my left but on the right
that there's a way where you can be
moral and it doesn't necessarily have
anything to do with religion or you can
be moral and it has to do with religion
but that's not how you want to be
governed I think
that's gonna be my takeaway from no I
think that's that's exactly right I mean
as I say to people who disagree with me
the beauty of the countries that you
don't have to care what I think
the minute you bring the government into
saying that I have to care what you
think
then we're at odds yeah so as long as
the government's out of it we can have
these discussions all day long and it's
just good fun
the minute you bring the gun to the
party or the fascist